what do you make of wall street bets
another thing that recently happened
that shook the world
and uh at least me from the outsider
perspective
make me question what i do and don't
understand about our economic system
uh which is a bunch of different a bun a
large number of individuals getting
together on the internet
and having a large-scale impact on the
markets
if you tell a group of people and
coordinate them through the internet
we're going to play a fun game it might
cost you money
but you're going to make the headlines
and there's a chance you'll screw over
some billionaires and hedge funds
enough people will play that game yes so
that game might continue but i don't
think it's of macro economic importance
and the price of those stocks in the
medium term
will end up wherever it ought to be so
these are
little outliers from a macroeconomics
perspective they're
they're not going to the these are not
signals of of shifting power
like from from centralized power to
distributed power these aren't some
fundamental
changes in the way our economy works i
think of it as a new
brand of esports maybe more fun than the
old brand
is fine right it's like push the anarchy
into the corners where you want it
it doesn't bother me
but i think people are seeing it as more
fundamental than it is it's a new esport
more fun for many but more expensive
than the old esports
like chess is a new esport super cheap
not as fun as like
you know sending hedge funds to their
doom but like
what would you expect the poetry of that
i love it okay
uh but macroeconomically it's not it's
not fundamental okay
i was gonna say i hope you're right
because i'm uncomfortable with the chaos
of the masses that's creates but uh i
also think that chaos is somewhat real
to be clear yes but it will matter
through other channels not through
manipulating
you know gamestop or yeah amc
you